hello hello all right I think it's about
time to start
okay
so I think I'll just jump on in and
that's that's what we'll do so all right
this is domain modeling in object
oriented and functional programming
and obviously when I saw the slides
today in the morning I realized well
that's a pretty long title right so
probably a little too much so I'll just
shorten it ever so slightly domain
modeling in oop and FP based on C sharp
and F sharp this is going to be a slight
comparison this is going to be quite a
lot of code and yeah let's see if you
like it but first of all well hello NDC
Oslo it's it's an absolute hey it's an
absolute pleasure to be here and I'm
really really stoked and just happy so
yeah let's move on
but first the Shameless black like
Martin Kern
um did you hear the name probably not
who the heck uh who the heck am I like
who are we talking about right
so I in my professional experience I do
about 10 years of commercial.net
development and I went through a lot of
different projects like CRM in Poland
through DNA in Poland and Germany that's
actually quite an interesting experience
I've gotta say and I'm moving towards
hearing aid in Denmark so somewhere
close or nearby should I say
I did different kinds of apps like even
started from a desktop app with with DB
beside it right and did some web
development with react or embedded
development also with react which is
kind of weird and I've been using using
Azure or Azure or however you want to
call it extensively I'm also a fan of
tdd fan of agile
but probably not too religious about
both of those
so yeah that's it in my private life I
do have a two-year-old son who's
absolutely amazing I've got even more
amazing wife and I do have some Hobbies
like we all do so some PC gaming digital
painting and when I'm just too damn
curious new programming languages and
probably that's where this whole talk is
coming from
so yeah that's cool fine but let's get
back to the topic that's that's why
we're here okay domain model
so what I want to talk to you guys about
is the why and how of DDD obviously we
won't cover the entirety of DDD that's
impossible in an hour simple as that so
let's first tackle why are we talking
about it in the first place
and I've got an example there's a lot of
examples ahead but imagine an
application where you are selling a
policy
for vehicles right so you're kind of an
insurance insurance company you're
selling policies
um what's interesting there is pretty
much the vehicles are divided in two
categories the private vehicles and the
fleet vehicles they obviously are the
same vehicle like underneath like the
model of the car and so on but in terms
of domain language it's actually a vast
difference
what else do we have we have in each
vehicle we actually have a black box and
if you don't know what that is you
should be thinking about the black box
in an airplane right so that's kind of
this device that is mounted into the car
by a professional mechanic and the
device will track pretty much the speed
of the car the possibility of or rather
whenever the crash happened what
happened during that time where the
brakes
um stepped on and so on okay and this is
this is what uh what is being done in UK
actually the black boxes are not
optional but they are just required
there
in terms of drivers we've got similar
story we've got Fleet drivers and
private drivers but the main difference
here is that the policy in general can
be sold for the whole Fleet or for a
particular driver and when we are
talking about particular driver we are
talk we are talking about particular
vehicle right so the policy is sold for
that exact vehicle
so how do we model this in a classical
approach I would call it
well my idea is quite simple we do have
a vehicle that has some types
and since there's always this one-to-one
relation between vehicle and black box
we can actually treat the black box as
part of the vehicle so we can go that
way so Black Box parameters are also a
part of vehicle here
we've got driver once again with two
types we've got policies with the
parameter of either the driver or the
fleet and here is
something a little bit more complicated
because we do have an optional parameter
because if the policy is sold to a
driver you've got an optional parameter
of vehicle because as I mentioned that's
that's the relation here right
and this is all fine and dandy so now
let's make a change
and the change is let's add a new type
of vehicle a short-term rental vehicle
and also what is probably most more
important a new type of black box and
this black box is actually movable
because this little this little black
box is now handled through putting it
into cigarette
um
cigarette space right
so that's how you can move the black box
from car to car
so what changed in the domain language
itself well we have a new vehicle
then we have new type of Black Box
because now the Black Box can be either
sold per vehicle this permanent black
box or per driver this one that is
movable right so the whole idea is that
the driver can switch between cars
uh what else changed changed nothing
much here apart from the fact that
private driver now can have the policy
bought for the vehicle or for the black
box that is movable
so that's the change
and in our output or in our classical
way what we have is those are the
changes in yellow right so we do have
first of all the new type of the vehicle
and now we have to extract the Black Box
obviously we could have done that from
the start but either way that's a change
now the Black Box have types and other
parameters and so on
what happened next is the driver has now
the optional parameter of Black Box
because once again the driver can have
the Black Box attached to it right
and the policy can be sold either for
the vehicle or for the black box or for
the whole freaking Fleet
so
it's nothing wrong with this approach
but
imagine we do a few more changes and
those are the projects that I've been
working on like some Legacy code usually
and there's a few more changes happening
and after a while you no longer
understand what's going on and first of
all well you have to play the human
compiler if you are talking about
somebody from the domain language you
have to just be the compiler and you
have to explain what does it mean for
him or rather understand what does it
mean for him and how it translates to
your code right
and well after a few more changes like
on top of those changes the new person
joining the team probably won't be able
to go from the code to domain language
it's actually opposite for you guys
sorry so this way around
and it's a hard thing to do it's a hard
thing to describe obviously we can solve
it by documentation but well who wants
to do that
so what's the other alternative the
other alternative is modeling The Domain
in the code so whatever you have on the
left side you put on the right side the
code and the domain is pretty much the
same
interesting trivia here the DB model
since it doesn't translate so easily it
can still behold in a classical way it
just needs to be abstracted a bit right
so this is exactly what I want to focus
on why because for the future pretty
much for the future is our answer to why
I do domain modeling so the first point
of how to do the domain modeling is
domain language and code should be the
same thing
and that I don't know about you but this
is exactly what was promised to me by
oop in in my like study years right this
is exactly what they meant like whatever
you have in real life you just translate
that into code and that all works
um unfortunately at least in the code
I've seen that's not really the case
okay second rule of domain modeling
let's move on
um so what I have in here another
example imagine a class or an object
that has those fields email initials ID
distance in kilometers like I seriously
don't know what that object is it's an
example but the question is what do you
do with validation of that right do you
have a separate validator class do you
have a method that is called validate do
you have got forbid Boolean value
validated but please don't do that never
please
but the questions arise right
also what about the operations
nobody in their right mind would add
email and initials it doesn't make any
sense but you can do that in the code
problem for the long run
in my opinion obviously
the same thing you can do with ID and
distance it's kinda
not what we want so what do we want we
pretty much want to well replace all the
basic Styles or the basic types sorry
so we can have control over those
validation in Constructor obviously
excluding the validation that is really
expensive if we have expensive
validation we do it completely
differently but for the simple types
validation in Constructor
and operations are getting really simple
because email plus initials that's a
compiler error you you won't be able to
run that code
and that's exactly what I want
so the rule is disallow incorrect state
to be represented in your code in the
first place
so to sum up two rules that I will focus
on today in terms of domain modeling is
domain language equals code and second
one is disallow incorrect state to be
represented in the code
and let's go to some meaty midi code
there so all right let's Model A vehicle
in object oriented programming
as I mentioned we replace the basic
types so we replace all of it the
vehicle has those five fields and as you
can clearly see those are only Getters
so pretty much once we create those
we're all set and done we're happy we
have to have a completely separate
Setter if we want one
the whole vehicle then
looks like this like the the Constructor
of the vehicle looks like this
um it's quite simple
oh it's not showing here sorry
oh here we go okay
um so the Constructor for the vehicle is
simple we get those parameters we just
check if they are nulls because they are
validated in their own Constructors so
we just check nulls and we're happy we
go we go over make vehicle make is a
special example here because that's just
a nanum so we it's not a null right
and I'll show you one of the
constructors of those types just as an
example once again registration number
it all in all after all
it does have the string inside because
we need to represent that somehow and
encode registration number is a string
and we do have some validation rules
they're quite simple we do take a look
at the length we do take a look at
disallowed characters and so on
and as always we have to care about the
null here
all right so what do we get by that how
do we use that vehicle then well usage
is as you can see in the line four
pretty much you create a vehicle you
create all of those
um registration numbers and parameters
and everything and then in line 11 you
no longer can replace registration
number with null which is exactly what
we want okay what else do we get we
cannot add registration number and the
model this is once again what we want so
good good job us
and one last thing and it's still not
showing okay I've got a look here sorry
um the last thing is when we run
registration number with a little too
long text
since I created it that way it just
throws an exception okay
if that's a good practice or not that's
a whole different discussion so let's
not go there now
and one more thing about object oriented
programming if you replace all those
types with new types it kinda gets
unwieldy I mean seriously it's only a
vehicle and we have already seven files
it's a little too much for me but then
again you don't want them all in one
file because that's not the convention
yeah it it can get messy
all right
so let's go functional finally right
but
stop stop for a moment because
yeah let me just cover some very basic
F-sharp
um things so you can understand the
examples and probably most of you guys
know this but it's only three slides I
promise it's gonna be quick
so what I want to show you guys is for
the F-sharp we don't have classes we
don't have objects so what do we have
um similarly it's still a dotnet
language so we have the similar
classical simple types like integer
floats booleans strings that's all there
right but for the complex types we do
have two
different things so we have
discriminated unions and think about
atoms but on steroids they are they are
actually better than enums and I'll I
will try to explain why
um second thing is records and if you're
thinking about records from c-sharp
that's exactly what it is because it's
just a class that cannot be changed and
is compared by the value rather than
reference
uh one important or interesting part
still is type inference but that's much
more easier to explain in the example
simple types as I mentioned nothing
special treat the treat the let
exactly like VAR in C sharp so it's just
let's test integer equals one that's an
integer and actually that the fact that
we didn't get the type or set the type
in any way is called type inference
but it goes a little farther than a
simple VAR in C sharp once again I will
show you that
all right so now the complex types those
are the more interesting so let's go by
those points that I mentioned here so
the first point gender this is actually
the discriminated Union so an num that I
mentioned right and when you see the two
number two
um that's that's what's interesting
about discriminated unions because you
can have the normal male female but you
can also have the other gender which is
actually a string underneath so when you
create a gender that is other you have
to explain what that really is what
exactly it is okay
um once again for male and female we
don't need strings
we just need it for for that third
option and that's actually kind of
interesting okay third point and this is
how we create records as I mentioned
those are very much similar to to
classes and objects so
there's nothing really special in here
um the the special part is number four
which is different than C sharp because
in C sharp we say list of the type and
here it's it's reverse right it's the
type list
okay let's go now let's go functional as
I promised
so model the vehicle in functional
programming
so once again replacing those basic
types
um and I usually do replace those basic
tiles by a single discriminated Union
value
you don't have to care too much about it
but the gist of it is it's string
underneath
it's it's like a wrapper for a string
exactly but since it's a wrapper we
cannot we cannot add them together like
two different types we cannot cannot
just interchange them all right
and in terms of vehicle itself number
nine or line number nine
uh that's a mouthful by the way
it's uh it's once again a record which
pretty much is just like a like an
object in C sharp right
I'm not sure why it's not showing up
sometimes but let's move on so very
similar I'll show you registration
number once again and I'll show you
something that it's not really a
Constructor but you can think about it
the same way and it's something that
allows us to construct the registration
number
um because it was actually marked as
private
and why do I do this obviously because I
want to have the same validation
so the same validation because I'm
checking out two things here in line 23
where we have the match this is pretty
much the same thing as switch from
c-sharp so we are matching for the
length of the number and remember the
number is a string and we're also
checking if there are some disallowed
character presents
um and yeah we're just checking the
length first line then we're checking
that
um these allowed characters are present
nothing too surprising here the same
logic as we had previously but
they're very like fun part is there is
no null check needed because well it's
it's functional uh you you cannot use no
All Right Moving On
how do we use that vehicle then
um once again we're just creating the
vehicle
um very similar thing
um you just have a little bit less
brackets here on the F-sharp side so
this is how you create it
and this is
um one more thing that we really needed
so we wanted not to be able or disallow
uh adding up registration number and
color model right
we have that here
success here we go
we also cannot change registration
number after creating the car because
it's functional so that part we get for
free
what else do we have in here this is
strictly like um
not really related to to the example uh
this is something I wanted to throw in
because usually we don't throw
exceptions in the constructors that's
probably not the greatest of ideas
what you could do is return something
return a type that once again is a
discriminated Union of either okay of
this record
or error with some explanations or
probably a string
and this is a little bit more common
practice so just just wanted to put it
out in here
now let's introduce to our vehicle one
more change in the domain space because
the vehicle now can have a engine that
is either gasoline based or electric
based
or actually a hybrid one and hybrid one
is just those two engines combined it's
usually not combined in a way that it's
one engine but rather a car have two
engines that are different from each
other one is gasoline one is electric
so how do we model that
all right let's start with object
oriented once again
so how do we do that how do we approach
it what I thought to do first of all is
add line 25 list of engines because once
again it can be one engine gasoline or
electric or it can be both of those
right
and it's kind of
very easy to to to follow along that you
will create an engine class and then
gasoline engine will inherit from that
electric engine will inherit for that
and the list of engines then makes sense
right and obviously you just assign it
in a Constructor
so let's see some things in here
since this is a list once again number
one we have to check if it's a null
number two we have to check still the
count like the length of that list
because as I mean as I mentioned it can
be only one or two it cannot be empty it
cannot be three
and number three if the count is exactly
two we have to make sure those are not
two Electric engines so we have to
compare the types of those somehow
all right so this is
this is how I would use it then so we
create the first engine that is gasoline
engine the second engine that is it
electric engine and then we pass along
in the line 18 list of those two engines
right
once again we are just really growing in
terms of classes here so just want to
mention that up
and we're done right
well not really
because well you can quite easily add an
engine afterwards so this approach
completely doesn't work right it's yeah
this is a little bit messed up
so what I thought to myself well let's
just exchange a list to an array the
array is a set number of items so if we
set one item we're good if we set two
we're good all good right sorry
but then again our eyes can also be
modified by set values so we still can
have two Electric engines so once again
that's not the right approach we
probably would have to create a new
class that is
overarching the list of engines and just
just have it in there right
let's go functional then how do we do it
functionally
so the idea is once again we create
gasoline engine and electric engine
and those two are actually a bit
different obviously
um one interesting fact that I found out
which I was not aware of I'm not a car
guy the coolant is actually completely
different in those two engines so you
really should not use the same class of
coolant volume in liters for both
because it's a completely different
Beast so you probably should create
gasoline engine coolant and electric
engine coolant
and what else is here interesting well
we do have some repetition actually
right because we do have the horsepower
here and there this is obviously
something that would land in a base
class usually in object-oriented
programming and in functional I would
accept that repetition but that might be
just my taste
let's move on how to how to use it and
this is something that I really really
like so once again what I wanted to do
is either gasoline or electric
or both right but never to Electrics you
can actually represent that as a one
Union type you have the gasoline
electric or hybrid and hybrid has a
subtype of those two gasoline and
Electric
so it's actually like described word for
word really
how do we use it we just into the
vehicle we just input that exact type
that type of our discriminated Union
all right
now how does it look in practice we
create first engine second engine and
then for the car at the very last line
of this this code we've got engine or
hybrid
um which is well we do hybrid and then
we just pass along those two engines
that's exactly what is happening in here
interesting trivia I mentioned that type
inference mechanism right so look at
number one I never said it's actually a
gasoline engine never never ever have I
said that it's once again inferred from
the type itself so as I mentioned it's
it's like VAR but it's a little bit
stronger probably
in general F-sharp is a little stronger
stronger types
um
going for it
and once again in terms of
file structure this is all I've been
doing right because those types those
simple types are so simple there are
one-liners
I can easily keep them in one file
there's nothing wrong with that so for
the engine I do have some other types in
there
and a bonus point because at this stage
of our functional functional writing or
functional modeling we already can model
Behavior so
um let's check it out
um I'm not showing here oop because I
assume you guys know exactly how to
write an interface for a method so I
just wanted to show you the other side
of the coin right
so without writing much implementation
we can create a type of the method that
will describe the behavior right
and let me just explain to you how to
read that so the type of the method is
the method accepts two parameters
vehicle and distance in kilometers
and it spits out another vehicle so that
one last thing after the arrow that's
actually an output from the function
okay you get in vehicle you get in
distance you speed out a new vehicle
can you guess what that is
I hope that wasn't
too complicated it was something of a
line of at a distance or at travel
distance and so on right
um if you are curious how it would look
like if you wanted to use it actually
that's line 59 for you so you create an
at distance traveled function
which is of the type of at the distance
and then you go on to create your own
function
and once again line 61 this is just
telling you that you are creating a new
vehicle based on that previous one you
just
changing the distance traveled so this
is a previous vehicle with distance
traveled obviously once again it's
functional programming so it's actually
a new record at the end so just wanted
to point that out and stress that out
all right and here comes the F-sharp
selling point for me personally
um
let me just show it to you
what we have in here
is the whole
um type structure of the vehicle right
and even included the behavior of the
vehicle obviously it's only one example
but you do have the behavior in here
and I would argue that once you explain
those arrows
you easily can show it to your subject
matter expert this slide you can show it
to him and you can discuss it with him
because he might mention all right cool
but we probably don't measure distance
in kilometers we do it a little bit
differently and so on and so on
already something that you can talk to
with a person that doesn't code
and I really think that's absolutely
Bonkers beautiful
all right
if I have sparked your imagination and
if I've managed to well get you curious
about F sharp I do have one beautiful
recommendation and that recommendation
is the name actually the person Scott
version
um he's amazing he's he's a legend in
F-sharp Community he's he's really
really great at explaining things he he
does that so well it's it's I'm
completely jealous and what he created
is a website that is called f sharp for
Fun and Profit
uh it's a whole website where you've got
pretty much everything F sharp explained
from the like very start to to Advanced
uh techniques so that is an easy
recommendation
um just a note for some time I don't
know why but the first link just didn't
work so it's also published by in git
books if you want to check it out it's
fully free
um you should be
I encourage you to check it out if you
want he also published a pretty cool
book called I think it was functional
domain modeling made functional
it's really awesome read I'd recommend
that quite heavily
if you want to stay in touch with me I'm
more than happy to do so so if I usually
use LinkedIn the most so if you want to
jump in and just pick my brain and talk
about stuff here and there don't
hesitate to add me if you can just
mention NDC to me so I so I know where
you're coming from so that would be that
would be absolutely lovely but I'm still
here I'm staying for the for the today
and tomorrow the whole day so if you
want to approach me and just grab a
couple cup of coffee and just talk I'm
more than happy to do so
um Instagram if you are interested I'm
using it a little not so much probably
LinkedIn is a better bet
and actually I think that's about it
from me so
do I see any questions guys
is there anything oh yeah okay now I can
see uh is there any questions you guys
might have
shoot
cool question thank you so the question
is about type inference right is there a
possibility that the type inference will
get it wrong yeah absolutely absolutely
it is and the easy thing is you can
always specify the type so
um if you have the same type or rather
the type that is pretty much looking the
same as the other one you can always
specify that here in this variable you
want to use that second type right so
that's that's actually
quite simple and quite quite nice thank
you
anything else guys
all right then uh once again
I'm here thank you very much guys for
attending and as always we can do better
as a pack thank you
[Applause]